the boy in me is slowly taking over my
body it's like that movie the fly but
replaced fly with his voice so I
shouldn't use the phrase boy and me also
also I accidentally did the Shocker oh
my god someone call a medic they're con
doctors there's a lot going on I'm in a
hotel room cries I didn't redo my home
with the hotel room aesthetic and I
walked through like a market grocery
store scenario because right now in the
middle of the day they don't have room
service until dinner's ready
so hungry and I got myself all the
essentials chicken Caesar salads and I
immediately destroyed crackers water and
more water hi my name is Republican uh
no now you know your life is different
now I went on my Twitter and asked you
guys what kind of video is with you
today and all of you said good news in
how much you know comment it was
confident and a couple you said it Oscar
related videos and the office
suggestions reminded me that I wanted to
do a review of the Oscar nominee so I
know you might be upset that it seems
like I'm not taking any of the
suggestions I initially asked for and
you are correct I'm not taking any
suggestions that I initially asked for
but I'm being inspired by them for the
Oscars are this weekend or the biggest
award shows and TV filming the TV and so
what are the Oscars
I know American Awards and we hosted for
the County of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences to recognize excellence in
cinematic achievements in the United
States film industry and assessed by the
Academy's voting membership just tell me
it's the movie award I haven't seen a
single nominated film is here I support
the Arts I thought be fun to do some
sort of review stream-of-consciousness
guessing the plot of economic films
based on the movie poster and you
suggested this but I'm student in any
way give him my audience exactly what
they didn't want nine movies nominated
for Best Picture I just realized that I
definitely did see Long Island but I'm
still going to get what the movie could
actually be based on the poster this is
going to be fun for probably only me
also I don't know what the official
there's a lot of purposes to this video
I'm so sorry I don't know what the
official movie poster is for any of
these movies but I'm going with the ones
that are on the oscar website
arrival
this is very clearly about a giant
coffee bean that comes to destroy earth
but plot twist the coffee bean is wildly
misunderstood it's not that it's trying
to destroy earth it's trying to get
someone to make it into coffee to
fulfill its full purpose everyone we
thought it was dangerous and really it's
got a heart of gold
oh it's also alive coffee normally gets
so much love when a coffee beans this
big where is the love the soundtrack is
by the Black Eyed Peas
and we think all hope is lost my
government has finally got the giant
coffee bean in its control
Godzilla shows up wearing a came buffers
coffee t-shirt and the rest is history
fences fences is clearly about Denzel
Washington and viola davis just shopping
at Home Depot being mildly unimpressed
with what kind of fences Home Depot has
been stopped and by all those like I
told you we should have gone to Lois and
denzel's like you know I can't go back
to load why I was like I've been trying
to forget about the pain exit for the
last seven years I think it's time we
can go back to load some pencils like I
ain't going back to low and then like a
tiny dog scurry buy them in the store
and nickels for a minute forget that
they are angry with each other
and then they buy a fence and spoiler
they decided to get some solar panels to
pack Saul Ridge I have not even heard
about this movie but it's clearly about
military rays wishing many films in the
military genre but we have yet to see a
film that focuses on the lesser-known
area of the military the military rave I
mean you know they say you gotta fight
for your right to party you can clearly
see that our two main characters take a
lot of ecstasy there's fog machine
Calvin Harris makes an appearance at
some point on plenty of booze Lucas this
offensive just might be getting
offensive let's move on however high
water ooh
this movie is about two door-to-door
salesmen just trying to get their stuff
back business off the ground
but their dad keeps showing up in the
sky like Mufasa tell them that they're
never going to get the funding for their
duffel bag so it's nice to leave
Oklahoma their own state by foot heading
to Los Angeles and get onto the set of
shark tank get Mark Cuban to give them
10% of their business back end with a
$50,000 investment on business works
it's called hell or high water because
the one brother's name is hell and the
other brother's name is high water the
dad did a lot of hallucinogenic and then
we're Cuban doesn't think that they
should be business partners so only one
of them has to choose to work with him
and the other one has to leave the
company at guys called hell or high
water which one's gonna run the duffel
bag business I mean neither of them is
Mufasa dad has its way in figures so I
kind of know the premise of this movie
but if I'm going off of this poster
alone under the guise that I have no
idea I said talking about three
competitive female power walkers that
just got back from space and are running
late for the championship power walking
competition but they all left their
sneakers in space so they gotta prove
that they can do it a way a real woman
does in very conservative heels a tail
of sports and triumph lala land like I
thought to solve it but based on this
poster this one is clearly about an
attractive man and attractive woman very
stylistically and obviously trying to
pickpocket each other in the hills of
Los Angeles
yes there pickpocketers but don't make
you want to empty your pockets to seize
it crime drama again and again lion-o
okay so this movie is about the giant
woman that lives under the local rural
tracks and the giant man that lives in
the sky that I've been in a staring
contest for thousands of years and their
gauge is broken when to run away Chimney
Sweeps
walking down the railroad tracks cross
paths with them and then there's this
giant wardrobe it's basically the rest
of the paw of the lion election wardrobe
Manchester by the sea okay this movie is
about couple that is struggling and the
guy as a spark to the relationship
decide on the really romantic like Beach
Harbor date but they get really sad and
pissed because there's so many seagulls
in their spot and they came son
the picnic because these people keep
trying to eat older [ __ ] and then I wear
they're always assuming people's one of
the seagulls is like no we just moved in
unless we've been talking is that yeah
and they're like what's your name is
like Manchester you know like okay could
you leave us alone
this doodles like oh sorry yeah totally
total misunderstanding
we'll move and then they have like a
decent date but they still break up
because it is not compatible couple it
happens ma night okay so my life clearly
about a guy that tried to follow YouTube
David Bowie makeup tutorial and the
results just work what he had hoped okay
there is my review slash just blind
assessment of all of the nominees for
Best Picture at the Oscars don't worry I
will definitely be doing an Oscars
fashion review next week let me know how
close I was to the plots of these actual
movie because I feel like I nailed all
of them every single one and not one of
them was even a little bit off in any
way whatsoever if you liked this video
click the thumbs up button below and
turn on my notifications is a little bit
like honors them you can turn on so you
get notified when I make videos because
this is content you don't want to miss
well the quickest button here is a
stretch my youtube channel because I'll
let you fill in that blank thanks for
watching see you next time I don't know
that works about like the one email
stone that did not want to be part of
Stonehenge and like went off and became
super evil and somehow grew really big
and it's coming back to avenge itself
against all the other stones that just
were such basic [ __ ] and the soundtrack
is nothing but twenty one pilots